many people didn't realize it but over
the weekend the sort of underpinnings of
a massive geopolitical confrontation and
even like a potential realignment of
political alliances started to ferment
and you know it's understandable here in
Boston we were very very busy as you
know Pat with the Red Sox in the
American League Championship Series the
Patriots played yesterday we had viral
videos all over the country of the
right-wing proud boys beating people up
in New York City which we'll talk about
a little bit later on in the program but
there is this big story taking place
where in Saudi Arabia is claiming to be
very ready to launch an economic war
against the West including the United
States if there are to be serious
repercussions for the alleged murder of
a journalist in the Saudi embassy of
Turkey in Istanbul so let's sort of take
a step back before we can really get
into the the analysis of it Saudi Arabia
I've been talking for years about how
relationships that exist with countries
like Saudi Arabia with a in some ways
diametrically opposed view of the world
and way of life in some ways quite
frankly those are relationships that
exist because of financial incentives
like arms deals and the desire for
stable oil prices these relationships
are only good as long as everybody plays
their role and keeps their mouth shut
when they need to and the United States
mostly has kept their mouth shut
over the atrocities committed by Saudi
Arabia against their own people even
against the atrocities committed by
Saudi Arabia against others the people
of Yemen recently would be one example
and basically the United States view has
been mild critiques but basically we
play nice because of the shared interest
in stability in the Middle East and
stable oil prices and arms sales and all
of the other things that we've talked
about on the program so let's now start
with the catalyst for this situation
which is that Saudi Arabia appears to I
don't know any other way to say it
appears
to have murdered a journalist named
jamal Khashoggi inside the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul Turkey or in some
place which he was brought to secretly
or covertly in some way shape or form
jamal Khashoggi was a big critic of
Saudi Arabia
he was an American resident but not a
citizen which some have chosen to focus
on including Donald Trump and we'll talk
about that in a little bit and Khashoggi
disappeared on October 2nd after
visiting the Saudi consulate in Turkey
in Istanbul Turkey and this
understandably hit a nerve with many
people both individuals and governments
have started to say something about this
my twitter feed over the weekend was
filled with individuals saying things
like for example Andrew Ross Sorkin who
was scheduled to participate in an event
in Riyadh who says he's not going
because of this incident but then more
importantly I would argue countries have
actually said wait a second this is
insane and maybe it's time for sanctions
as an example we had 22 American
senators who pushed for an investigation
into the possibility of sanctioning
economically Saudi Arabia over this
incident and this was immediately bad
for Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia's stock
market dropped as much as 7% biggest
drop since 2014 lost 33 billion in value
last week a shaky start already this
week so this is having an impact in
Saudi Arabia and Saudi Arabia
immediately threatens to retaliate to
any possible economic sanctions
according to their news news agency
s.p.a
basically saying we will screw the world
if you do this a quote attributed to an
official Saudi source by the s.p.a the
kingdom affirms its total rejection of
any threats and attempts to undermine it
whether by threatening to impose
economic sanctions using political
pressures or repeating false accusations
the kingdom also affirms that if it
receives any action it will respond with
greater action and that the kingdom's
economy has an influential and vital
role in the global economy
initially Donald Trump sort of seemed to
be taking the pro
that Khashoggi is a resident but not a
citizen so we're not really gonna do
anything
and then he issued a possible threat on
60 minutes
but trump as usual seeming like his main
priority is what has been us priority
for a long time not hurting for-profit
companies he called them jobs but what
we're talking about here is the
military-industrial complex here is
Trump on 60 minutes talking about this
Jamaal Khashoggi the journalist the
Saudi journalists was he murdered
by the Saudis and did the Prince give
the order to kill him well nobody knows
yet but we'll probably be able to find
out it's being investigated it's being
looked at very very strongly we would be
very upset and angry if that were the
case as of this moment they deny it and
did not deny it vehemently could it be
them yes Jared your son and laws got on
the phone and asked the prince did he
what did he deny it did they deny it
they denied every way you can imagine in
the not-too-distant future I think we'll
know an answer what are your options
let's say they did what are your options
would you consider imposing sanctions as
a bipartisan group of senators have
proposed what depends on what the
sanction is I'll give you an example
they are ordering military equipment
everybody in the world wanted that order
Russia wanted it China wanted it we
wanted it we got it
and we got all of it every bit of it so
would you cut that off well I don't know
what I don't want to do Boeing Lockheed
Raytheon all these cuts I don't want to
hurt jobs I don't want to lose an order
like that and you know there are other
ways of punishing to use a word that's a
pretty harsh word but it's true the
pattern is deferring to denier stating
that someone has denied it so on
Khashoggi x' disappearance he says it
was a firm denial on russian election
interference Putin denied it very
strongly he said during that Helsinki
summit if Saudi Arabia had nothing to do
with Washington Post journalist Jamal
Khashoggi disappearance why haven't they
released video of
leaving the Saudi consulate in Turkey
he's then in Turkey and it you could at
least make a stronger case doesn't have
anything to do with Saudi Arabia
although it still could trump by saying
that other people have denied X Y or Z
just provides cover for them and buys
them time and then the latest this
morning as Trump was getting ready to
get on Air Force One to head down to see
the hurricane damage was it could have
been rogue killers who did it take a
listen this is like when he says anyone
could have meddled in the election
there's lots of people in the world that
could have been rogue killers could be
anybody but it's important to say that
we make fun of Trump a lot and what he's
saying is providing cover for Saudi
Arabia but the truth is that this
reaction this sort of well they deny it
and we don't want to hurt American
companies we don't want to we'll take it
very seriously though but we don't want
to hurt jobs this is inevitable because
of our policy towards Saudi Arabia and
our relationship the u.s. is now in a
situation where if you simply cannot
ignore what Saudi Arabia is accused of
doing and you do decide to put sanctions
on Saudi Arabia our economy is so tied
into theirs by choice that we hurt
ourselves by sanctioning them and
there's a very good op-ed in Al Arabiya
by Turkey Alka Diehl who runs a la vía
who says that if indeed the US sanctions
Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia could push the
price of oil up to $200 a barrel which
would be crippling for our economy and
it's not just oil we also have
information sharing with Saudi Arabia
that could be cut I'm not saying I like
this stuff I'm just explaining to you
that it's by our own doing we haven't a
way of life that's based on oil so now
Saudi Arabia can destroy us by
manipulating the oil market many of our
huge companies that employ people employ
people specifically because of arms
sales to countries including Saudi
Arabia so they have us over a barrel now
how many different ways could this have
been averted men
right not having these ties to Saudi
Arabia now you see how climate change is
a national security issue when we say
fossil fuels and our per capita use of
them for our lifestyle is a national
security issue this is why if we get off
of our oil addiction this matters way
less to us and if we don't like the
humanitarian authoritarian theocratic
mess that is Saudi Arabia and we claim
not to like it we could as a country
really do something to stop it if we
didn't need them to play nice with the
oil market and to keep buying our
weapons we keep having a party
Republicans that say climate change is a
hoax it's an attack on coal and fossil
fuels it's a conspiracy if gas prices go
to 8 to 10 bucks a gallon that will make
everything shipped by truck more
expensive groceries products everything
that will make vacationing by car or
plane insanely expensive which will
crush the tourism industry of course we
should be doing this to Saudi Arabia or
if we're going to do it but we should
have been doing it all along because now
to punish them we have to punish
ourselves and the American people and
one more thing for everybody saying the
Saudis would never do it because they
need to sell oil to make money they've
got enough money bundled away where they
could do this and not sell us a drop of
oil for a very long time they're gonna
be fine they'll still have their nice
cars and their private 747s and all of
the other stuff